now that we have a visual sense of what
this common tangent with a positive
slope would look like let's see if we
can get some constraints on it
especially constraints on its slope and
y-intercept so this line this line that
I drew in the last video here in pink it
would have the form y is equal to MX
plus B it's a line where m is the slope
and B is the y-intercept
where B is the y-intercept now what I
let's think about what what constraints
that would have to be on M and B if this
is tangent if this is tangent to the
circle and you might be tempted to break
out some calculus and figure out the
slope at any point along side a circle
but there's an easier way to do it you
just have to realize that if a line is
tangent to a circle it will only
intersect that circle at one point let
me show you what I'm talking about so
this is the line what I want to do is
figure out where this equation and the
equation of the circle intersect that's
what we'll focus on in this video and
then we'll do the same thing for the
hyperbola so we have Y is equal to MX
plus B is the equation of the line the
circle they give us the equation up here
x squared plus y squared minus 8x is
equal to 0 so the circle is x squared
plus y squared minus 8x is equal to 0 so
we have what we can do is we can
substitute this expression over here we
can substitute this in for Y and then we
can figure out what does M and B or what
are the constraints on M and B so that
we only have one solution to the
intersection where we only intersect at
one point so to do that actually let's
substitute for Y squared so if Y is
equal to this let's square that we'll
get Y squared I'm just squaring the
expression for the line y squared is
going to be cool M squared x squared
plus 2 m bx plus b squared all i did is
i squared this expression here and I did
that so now we can substitute this whole
thing right in here right in here for Y
squared and so our the X point
the expression for the ex point for our
intersection is going to be x squared
plus all of this business that's the y
squared plus M squared x squared plus 2
m bx plus b squared minus 8x minus 8x is
equal to 0 and if we wanted to write
this as a quadratic in terms of X this
would be so our x squared terms are
these 2 terms so this is we could write
this as let's see let's write this is M
squared plus 1 times x squared right M
squared plus 1 times x squared and then
our X terms are this one and this one so
then we have plus plus 2 m be minus 8
times X and then we just have this B
term this B squared the constant term
right over here and I'll do that in
orange so plus B squared is equal to 0
so if we knew m and B if we knew the
equation of this line this would just be
a straight-up quadratic you could use
the quadratic formula to figure out the
x-values where they intersect now what's
neat about this is we know that they
only have to intersect in one point
remember the quadratic formula negative
b plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac all of that over 2a
and I'll get this be confused with the
y-intercept B this is just the B from
the quadratic formula
that's the quadratic formula over there
this will only have one solution will
only have one solution if this over here
is equal to if this over here is equal
to 0 because then you're just put you're
just adding and subtracting 0 so you're
only going to get one solution so when
something when a line is tangent to a
circle it can only intersect in one
point or another way to think about this
will only have one solution if a line
intersects any other type of non tangent
line a non tangent line would do
something like that it would either have
two solutions in which case this is a
positive value or it won't intersect at
all or it won't intersect at all and
then this will have no solutions which
means that b squared minus 4ac
would be a negative number so we know
that this is a tangent line this is a
tangent line so we only have one
solution or b squared minus 4ac is equal
to zero
so what's B squared minus 4ac over here
well this is our B but when we think in
terms of the quadratic formula and
remember don't get that be confused with
the B of the y-intercept I'm just
thinking of the quadratic formula here
so let's do this let's take this squared
so I'm just going to rewrite this
expression and set it equal to zero
because we know there's only one
solution so we have to M be minus eight
squared and then you have minus four
minus four times a which is M squared
plus one times C times C is V squared
times C is B squared and so this is
going to have to be equal to zero if
this is truly a tangent line if this is
truly a tangent line so let's see any
type of interesting things that we can
get out here if we can have if we can
express B and as a function of M let
that's a good place to start so let's
try to do that so let's see if we expand
this out this becomes four M Squared let
me do that in the same blue so you know
what I'm expanding out this part over
here becomes four M Squared B squared
for M Squared B squared minus two times
8 is 2 times negative eight is negative
16 multiply that times 2 so it's
negative 32 MD I'm just squaring this
over here plus 64 so that is that term
over there
expanded - minus 4 times let me write
this well I can just expand everything
out minus 4 times M Squared B squared
minus 4 times 1 times B squared minus 4
B squared is all going to be equal to 0
and then lucky for us some of these
terms cancel out 4 MB squared negative 4
MB squared and let's see we could
actually divide everything both sides of
this equation by 4 and we get we get
negative 8
M b-plus we're dividing everything by 4
so plus 16 minus B squared is equal to 0
and now we can solve for B in terms of M
using the quadratic formula again so now
we would have a constraint or we would
essentially know what our y-intercept is
going to be in terms of our slope and
then we can do that with a hyperbola and
then we can essentially say well it's
the same line so the y-intercepts have
to be the same and then we can solve for
the slope so let's do that and you'll
see that over the next few videos so let
me just write this in a form that we
would recognize this is the same thing
well let me just let me just actually
and let me just multiply this equation
right here both sides by negative 1 so
then it would become b squared plus 8 m
b minus 16 is equal to 0 i just
multiplied this by negative 1 and just
rearranged the terms now let's solve for
B in terms of M so B is going to be
equal to negative 8m negative 8m plus or
minus the square root plus or minus the
square root of this term squared so it's
8 squared M squared minus 4 times a
which is just 1 times C which is 16
minus 4 times negative 16 so this is you
could view this as plus 4 times 16 plus
4 times plus 4 times 16 all of that all
of that over 2a
well a here is just 2 all of that over 2
now this is going to be equal to
negative 8m plus or minus now this is 64
this is 64 so we can take out you could
factor out the 64 from here but when you
take the square root of it it's going to
be 8 times M Squared 8 times M squared
plus 1 right if you took the 8 in you
would have to square it so it becomes 64
and 64 times M squared plus 64 which
exact which is exactly what you had up
there all of that all of that over 2 and
then we can simplify this is equal to
negative 4
plus or minus four times the square root
of M squared plus one so this is this is
a possible B given that the line is
tangent given that the line is tangent
to the circle now let's just think about
this a little bit if we if we add four
if we add four we're definitely going to
have well let's think about it for a
second if we look at the line up here
the way I draw we want a positive slope
we want a positive slope and in order to
do that the way I drew it you have to
have a positive y-intercept so this is a
positive let me just write it this way
this is a positive this is a positive be
a positive y-intercept so we want this
value we want to think about the
y-intercept that is positive now M is
going to be positive we know from the
problem that we're looking for a
positive slope so M is positive so
negative for this whole term is here is
going to be negative so only chance of
being positive is so if we add four
times this expression right over here
and actually if you look at it it will
be positive because this is greater than
M Squared so this is going to be the
square root of that's going to be
greater than M so four times this is
going to be greater than four M so if we
add it's going to be positive so we want
to only look at the B is equal to
negative four M plus 4 times the square
root of M squared plus one I'll leave
you there for this video in the next
video we're going to do the exact same
thing for the hyperbola realizing that
the line will only intersect at one
point and then since it's the same line
we know that their B's have to be the
same we're going to in the next video
we're going to get a B is equal to some
other function of M is equal to some
other function of M we're going to get
that in the next video and then we could
set them equal to each other and solve
for our M and then once you solve for an
M you also have solved for the B and
we'll have our line